[Applause]
this is very cool I'm standing here with
Tracy Inman
co-director of the famed Alvin Ailey
School of Dance
thank you so much for having me here
today you're welcome nice to meet you
I've come here because I would like to
master this form of dance what's your
background when I was a kid and this is
a true story I did take tap-dancing for
a couple of years it's not the response
I was hoping you'd be like oh and maybe
high five me but that didn't happen
let's do it
so I burned my bag they had my tights
and there was a thong and I've never
worn a thong before it's not a thong
it's a dance belt I know but as a song
back goes up this into my bottom before
it's time for everything
all the other guys have that same thing
you won't be lumpy with a roomful of
guys in thongs yeah exciting huh this is
Conan he's gonna join our class today
hi Damaris Damaris beautiful name you
know it's good to see you hello nice to
see you what's your name
Maya hello great grace nice to see you
guys again nice to see you
hello how are you you're obviously in
great pain can you say this is a little
confession this is my first time in my
life wearing a thong acclimated you're
doing well it feels very strange I feel
like I'm smuggling something through
customs guys just say with me for a
second can I just keep an open mind I
was just I thought when I saw the
leotards it was gonna be more of this
kind of thing you know is this what
we're doing today and not boys what is
this more I don't know what that is you
take the Hat you kind of put it forward
and you do the old this thing and then
you do one of these okay wait
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay at the end I'll admit I just did
that and I apologize but I thought I did
pretty good you did excellent
give me your grade between like an A and
an E
hey what you would say yeah now you're
just being an [ __ ] one and two three
and four five whole six seven eight over
lavell t 9 10 11 12 13 15 16 17 18 19
2014 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 promenade
29 31 32
people support me when I do that
physically
now I want you to take your rib cage and
move it to the right forward now stop
and move it back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know this uh ballet move it's from the
play the proud rabbit
[Applause]
you're moving across the floor which is
right I went up I thought I was in
rhythm yeah sir was I not in rhythm yes
you were
you have a job in Los Angeles whatever
you need now we got something really
challenging for you 1 & 2 & 3
up down 1 2 up down Oh what - right leg
forward left leg forward I suppose we
could use his body and then in editing
put my head breathe it's pretty much a
match
[Applause]
the safe place it's not well because
you're in the perfect position to do
coccyx palace sit down more
I want to tip over okay there stay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
all right the rest of you may remain in
the dance troupe we're now all over
drivers this is an honor to meet you and
this what you see can I be part of the
truth right part of the company right
you didn't say anything that's right I'm
very proud of what I've learned today
and I can't wait to show you
[Applause]
you